hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace and
Helbig today we have Willem back for
another round of not too deep and this
time Willem is joined by none other than
laganja estranja and this is a beautiful
episode we get into all of it you never
know what to expect when Willam is a
guest and that's exactly what you can
expect on this episode we talk about
what William's been up to since a star
is born we talked about laganja and our
impact in the cannabis community and how
she's AA big plans big plans for what
she's building in the cannabis world I'm
so excited for you guys to hear about it
also how they've been doing drag and
supporting each other and how you can
support your fellow drag queens during
this quarantine they're getting creative
y'all and it's something to see oh and
not only is are we all seeing what
laganja's been up to doing live drag
shows from her driveway but Willam is
her neighbor so you get two for the
price of one in this episode tip them
both at the end enjoy this episode of
not too deep with Willam and laganja
[Music]
okay thank you guys for being here I
mean it looks like you just rolled out
of bed both of you beautiful mm-hmm
first of all I have to ask you how are
you doing
amidst all of this nonsense
you
got it I've been having a hard time
trying to find my happy so I've been
saying no to a lot of like online drag
stuff and like like interviews and lives
just because like I don't want to be
fake right now so I'm just trying to
like be really honest with people that
I'm scared as [ __ ] the dicks and I'm
subscribed to my youtube channel I
appreciate the honesty because I feel
like there must be a little bit of
pressure to have to figure out how to
continue to perform with everything
that's happening and to your credit I've
been looking at all of your instagrams
and YouTube videos and everything you
guys have been adapting amazingly he's
really I'm sure that she's gained
thousands of new fans just from the
warranty [ __ ] she's been putting out me
watching over the fence with like
popcorn I'm like yeah hey neighborhood
watch is coming around saying yeah I
mean I just feel really lucky that what
we do what our art form is translated
into the digital platforms I think that
you know because we do have following on
Instagram and all the social media we're
lucky in the way that we can put a show
on our backyard like put a show on in
our backyard and still receive tips and
donations from dolls and doll fans so
you know I think it's a blessing I feel
like yes it's challenging but it's for
me at least it's been fun because for
instance I can't bring a car into the
club but in my driveway it's no problem
so I'm trying to like use it in creative
ways oh I saw yeah your entrance if
you're just driving in on your car in
your driveway
I couldn't even brain that as a
possibility of something that you could
do during quarantine so kudos to you for
being so creative and how you're able to
still perform for people live I mean it
that's what happens when you smoke weed
so I want to know first of all what is
the two of yous origin story do you
remember when you first met each other
she remembers
the very first time we met was actually
at bored nerves right next to your
studio and I was with my dear friend
who's no longer with us Bobby Webster
and I bumped into you and you asked me
my drag name and I told you that it was
laganja and you were like oh that's a
clever name so that's why the next time
when I saw your [ __ ] action you're like
huh what's your name I'm like oh you say
you like my name it was good you know I
I definitely
maybe I got hazed but I think it's just
because like you know people who do drag
really care about this art form and when
a newbie comes in its natural to like
yeah you know pick on them a little bit
so I think it was okay the real story it
was because someone said you slept with
my other friend's boyfriend yeah well I
did yeah I tried to sleep with him too
why does that matter you why my hater
who knows we got over it yeah it feels
like I mean it's almost like an indirect
sign of love to take the time to make
fun of someone right and like you said
like a form of hazing at what weight
does it become do you break through the
hazing and there's like an acceptance of
okay you're cool now if the person cries
that means they could be your friend
basically means that me and detox tried
to do it to misty viola and she wouldn't
cry okay you could be our friend now
because she was our understudy in a play
person fired from it so that's one more
yeah
Willem what's the post a star is born
life for you been like if anything
changed the gigs that I'm offered and I
try to create more of my own I've gone
on a lot of meetings no one signed me
for acting yet still Wow yeah which is
crazy for me because I thought I was
really funny in the movie yeah you were
yes I did get an agent out of
for like reality stuff and like that
kind of stuff so I'm working on
different shows and hoping something
comes down the line
that you know it's fun and cute and it's
work but nothing's changed really really
well I mean maybe that's a blessing in
disguise amazing and laganja you're
massive in this dance world what I know
I was just watching a little bit of the
documentary of the International like
what do you describe it as the dance
kind of a curated and crafted piece that
you did I'm not for sure which one are
you talking about laganja's dance school
or the thing I did with young arts the
thing with young arts okay yeah that was
a it was a grant I was given as an
artist to come in for three weeks and
create a piece of art basically it was
like an open workshop I just happened to
take it really really seriously
so I created like a 40-minute
installation art piece inside of the
jewel box which is a building that young
art's owns in Miami and had audience
members for tea at a time walked through
this kind of experience that really
explored gender so it started with Adam
and Eve and then it broke it down all
the way until we ended in sort of a room
that represented being non-binary which
is what I consider myself to be gender
fluid so that was a really cool really
cool thing that I got to do because
that's my real passion as much as I love
drag I got my BFA and dance and
choreography so that's always been the
end goal with this is to have my own
dance company and to be the artistic
director choreographing and you know
touring the company around the world and
then maybe if I'm still feeling and I
can go to all these gay clubs that I've
made connections that I put on a little
afterparty
but that's amazing it what kind of I
mean how do you even approach a project
like that because it does seem very
different than what you do in drag in
like you said you were taking it much
more seriously I mean is that a totally
different brain than you use when you
create the drag performance
I would say yes and no I think a lot of
it has to do with my training as I said
I've never really intended on being a
drag queen I always say that drag chose
me because I really did I just wanted to
be a choreographer that's what I went to
study at the California Institute of the
Arts but what's been really cool about
the whole drag process is it's taught me
how to do makeup and wigs and costuming
and all of these you know skills that I
think I will end up using as the
creative director of my dance company so
for me I try to keep the brains like
fluid as well just like my gender mama I
just try to keep it all as one
simultaneously hamster wheel that's
circling because I think everything is
is counter balancing and talking to one
another so it's not like okay I'm doing
drag here I'm only gonna be gay I mean
I've danced contemporary and dragged
many times so I liked I like to bend the
lines of what is dance and try to find
somewhere in between that's really
beautiful
well I'm equally beautiful you are
exploding watermelons on your YouTube
channel with rubber bands which is also
you know in and of itself its own art
why is it did you know when you put
yourself out there on the Internet how
deeply are you taking like suggestions
and recommendations from your audiences
because I assume that that was something
recommended for you to do she takes a
deep I'm very open to suggestions I keep
saying like I'm almost out of ideas for
the internet but there will always be
more ones and like I'll see someone do
something and I could be like they think
that I need to try that like because I
didn't know this watermelon happened
like who knew and then it just started
squirting at me a little bit getting mad
I broke it now it's not gonna blow up
but I kept doing it and then it blew up
and I was so happy it was like part of
my day and it felt like summer just a
dream watermelon yeah there's a lot of
symbolism in that video I could see a
lot of the art about you know it mirrors
what's happening in society right down
Bay
yeah and just like just like the
watermelon after quarantine someone's
gone busted open feel free to take
whatever you want I'm ready
gorge you you live next door to each
other was this purposeful I yeah I
definitely texted all my friends and
told them hey there's a place next door
there's a guesthouse and then a front
house and like I wanted my friends to
live there because friends are better
yeah of course yeah especially now
neighbors that drag together stay
together it's true mm-hmm amazing
amazing man in the front house which
might be open so we're thinking about
having a bathroom pageant where we just
have people drive by and compete for the
spot in the new bedroom yeah it and tell
you when can't see Anna and the entrance
fee is two thousand dollars plus a
security deposit person laughs another
creative way to thrive in quarantine
also will have you been doing beatdown
for how long now um a gazillion 70 years
since 2012 it just really keeps growing
and getting worse and then better and
more fun and I love it because like
these are videos now that I can like
shine a light on people like like during
the beatdown I've been showing
quarantine videos with girls so like
people could see it if they miss their
lives be like go chip this [ __ ] sheeni
had helped her fish mrs. Welham got me
tip tiny she put my little hot box video
in there and the kids went wild I saw
that it's a great way to collaborate
window it was like a drag queen got put
through the mouse trap operation game
where it just drops that is laganja i
love that also Willem you have your your
makeup line collection right because
there were some issues with Marilyn I'm
wearing her today gorge
mm-hmm I love it now what is what's the
creative process when you go into making
products or merch for yourselves because
obviously makeup is something that
you're very knowledgeable about but it's
also a place where people can be really
critical like how do you how do you like
decide what you're gonna make and how
you're gonna make it for me what I
wanted to make for my makeup line was
all based on what I used for drying and
how I wanted to make my career as easy
and accessible for as long as I wanted
to do it without like people you know
we're going out of business you don't
have foundation anymore so I'm doing
stuff that mostly you don't need brushes
for because I don't think the world
needs another palette anywhere so I do
like top coats for lips I do glitter
gels that you could just put over
anything and I do big lashes just
basically the three things you need to
get drag I think a lash a lip and then
some glitter and some shine so I'm
concentrating on those and trying to
just do stuff that I like former Chinese
right ooh think about other people and
what they would want to wear first but I
always try to do merch that I would
would at least be happy wearing -
definitely and for me what I like to
concentrate on is concentrates you know
THC things that'll get you high you're
looking to expand my cannabis lifestyle
brand yeah I'm going to get my t-shirt
okay meanwhile laganja you're you're
obviously in the cannabis community
which i think is so cool and very
important especially for young people to
kind of normalize it because i feel like
there is such a bizarre stigma around it
and there shouldn't be in my opinion was
that something to just kind of like
naturally fit in your lifestyle is this
like i'm gonna be talking about this i
want to do collaborations with
pre-rolled joints like i want to do this
kind of thing yeah it was absolutely a
conscious choice I feel like any good
drag queen or beauty queen should have a
platform that they stand on that's
bigger than themselves and for me the
reason I chose cannabis is because it
really did change my life you know I
grew up in Texas Dallas Texas where it's
very conservative cannabis is seen as
the devil's lettuce and so
you know I always had a yeah negative
stigma of being a you know at that time
what I would call a drug user but it
wasn't until I came to California and I
discovered that it really is truly
medicinal I got my medical license at
the time under proposition 215 which is
also known as the compassionate act
which was actually founded founded by
the LGBTQ AI plus now community so I
feel like a real sense of history or her
story if you will that I need to live up
to and so that's why I try to be very
active not only as a cannabis user and
activist but also as a queer person
because I think there's a lot of space
that needs to be cleared in the industry
unfortunately it's very homophobic so
right now it's up to individuals such as
myself to really you know change that
and embrace different communities I
think that's fantastic and I think now
we're the never like you're saying it's
I know a lot of very anxious people that
have dealt with anxiety and things like
that have found like a lot of safe haven
in cannabis and has like expanded their
whole you know socializing everything
about their their lives and I think it's
so important just be like this is a
positive product are there any future
collaborations in the works on anything
yeah I'm definitely doing something with
puff Co for the month of cried so you'll
definitely want to stay tuned to see
what exactly that's going to be and then
my partnership with fruits labs is of
course ongoing we started a partnership
last year during Pride Month actually
where I created my own individual flavor
for the company so unfortunately this
year I didn't get to create a new flavor
because of kovat but we all we still
offer it year-round so my flavour that I
did last year which is the pride passion
is still available it's a little leather
all organic vegan gluten free and kosher
certified wow that's incredible I didn't
even know that that was possible
exactly see that's why I don't have a
lot of products right now it's because I
only want to put my name on things that
are truly you know forging new ground
and I think healthy edibles is totally a
way we need to be looking and
slurring because personally I don't want
to have to eat a brownie every time I
want to get medicated so you know our
fruits lab is this big it's ten
milligrams super easy and healthy
amazing I like this look Willem I also
to cover my beer because I had a beard
the queen of merch she has I mean these
rags I'm sure you can imagine what
they're for I think she's so she's so
smart your there is a demand so create
the supply now you guys have such a
great rapport and support for each other
is there an etiquette to calling each
other out on things if you see each
other sporting a look that isn't what
you think they should be doing like how
do you how do you do that while she's
already wearing a sue any memories for
better or worse of the worst looks that
you've sported in the past for the black
and white challenge
I looked insanely yeah definitely one of
my worst great what your promo look oh
yeah I liked I I bought one of those
body strappy things like you're wearing
the denim one that you had for my video
oh yeah remember your garage sale with
gia at Wow
yeah filming that Dani I literally
walked across street I was like well
this or and I were in the video that day
well actually yeah the strappy dinner
with the tits uh-huh it's just endless
endless support laganja you're
also um driving on tik-tok I hear
thriving but I would say slowly gaining
momentum yes okay what are your thoughts
on tick-tock I haven't fully immersed
myself in that world yet so sure any
advice or anything on it well I'll be
very honest with you I literally just
started to talk this year because I was
one of those people who was like I'm not
getting another app this is a dumb but a
lot of my friends convinced me because I
am a dancer and it is so heavily based
in doing dance that I should start it
and so naturally when I started it I
just thought it was so silly it's
covered with like you know 19 year old
boys shirtless thinking they can dance
hip hop and I just like the most random
things that I totally do go down a
rabbit hole on but ultimately when I'm
filming the tech talks I'm doing the
dances I have the time of my life
so I have you know kind of committed to
the app because especially during
quarantine you know the days when I
don't feel like doing anything even if I
just get out and film a 15-second
tick-tock
it really does improve my mood because
that's what I love to do I love to dance
so I guess my advice to you would be
decide like what it is it's gonna be
your niche because chick talk is very
that it's very like you're a dancer or
you're a good lip syncher or you're
funny a comedy or you work with your mom
and you do mom and son I mean it is it's
like very yeah it's like YouTube almost
where there's kind of genres so I guess
if you wanted to be successful at going
viral I would say to figure out you know
what is your niche and then to push it
good to know Willem have you gotten into
tik-tok to watch ado toss this video for
mass club space fry yeah watching and
then I wanted to be like I wonder if she
minds and then I was gonna ask I hope
you know and then my shoe care there was
one time though where I was like in my
robe I think I was doing a Beyonc no I
was doing the JLo challenge which is
really hard the one she did with learned
it yet so she may mean
because I was still trying to learn it
oh my god just shoot at me with like a
super soaker okay feel like you're just
being Wilson from home-improvement just
like standing over the fence the whole
time but she gives full-face you know he
always only did like that right face
fantasy I shall buy a shop suck let's
make some body where the [ __ ] name is
I love that you keeping all the
imperfections all the bloopers all like
the things that you [ __ ] up and it just
adds to the whole brand it's really
great okay we're gonna take a quick
break when we get back I have more
questions for you then we have a ton of
Twitter questions for you so we'll be
right back with more not too deep you
have a bunch of stuff laying around the
house that you don't use you probably
definitely do and we've all had the time
to just stare at it and wonder how and
why it got into our locations to begin
with I'm talking about like kids old
baseball gloves or those jeans that you
were once or never wore and you had high
hopes for but now they're in the back of
the closet or like a phone that's in a
drawer somewhere we all have a phone
drawer well there's an app that you can
use to sell all this stuff it's called
Macari Macari is the selling app that
makes it fast and easy to sell almost
anything it's super simple you just take
a couple pictures of your stuff you add
a description and bam your item is
listed and once it's sold Macari emails
you a shipping label and you just stick
it on and send it off there's no meetups
there's no hassles and with millions of
people using the Macari app in all 50
states your stuff will really sell and
the app has over 600,000 reviews on the
App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try super
easy
no meetups no hassles and you can get
rid of all that stuff that makes you go
why every time you look around don't let
that stuff you don't use go to waste
sell or buy almost anything on my car
you can find Macari on the app stores
on Mercury calm that's em er ciear hi
Macari the selling app too deep right
now is the time that all of us are
struggling with some sort of stress or
anxiety or isolation or depression and
you're not alone we're all going through
it and if you're curious in something
that can help you out better help better
help offers online licensed professional
counselors who can help their counselors
specialize in issues like depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma anger family conflicts lgbtq+
matters grief self-esteem and more you
can connect with your counselor in a
safe and private online environment
anything you share is confidential you
fill out a questionnaire to help assess
your needs and you get matched with a
counselor in less than 24 hours and from
there you can easily schedule secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapists plus exchange unlimited
messages I've had friends that use this
app and love it it's so much especially
because you have the ability to text
with your counselor everything's super
confidential and super convenient to you
wherever you are however you want to
communicate and if for any reason you're
unhappy with your counselor you can
request a new one at anytime for no
additional charge it's an affordable
option and you guys will get 10% off
your first month of this already
affordable option with the discount code
grace that's better help btter heelp
comm slash grace discount code grace
talk to a therapist online and get help
okay look Andra because you're in the
dance world what are your thoughts on on
Dance Moms I mean I love it I'm a huge
supporter you're talking about the
television show or the actual people and
I'm talking more like the actual people
that the TV show but as someone who did
teach at a dance studio for 10 years
mothers are very intense I've definitely
had you know a few across the many years
that I taught for 10 years that I loved
and still keep in touch with but for the
most part I found them to be you know
overbearing very intense
it's like if you were to have a private
they would want to sit in and watch tell
like side coach so you know I mean I had
a stage dad but he was nowhere near like
a stage mom there they're truly their
own special creatures and so they're
real they exist in Rio yeah and they are
as intense as they're portrayed on
television mother's living through their
daughters yes that exists mama do you
share a memory that you guys have had
together that stands out above anything
else like what's the best memory or
experience that you've had together mean
gays right we engage we did a play
together with kimchi and peaches Christ
and a bunch of really cool drag
performers in like six cities in 2019
Wow what was that experience like well
she was Regina George
but named of course Willem George and I
was playing Karen I forget what my what
was my name I don't know the Dijon just
laganja smith we would just go to
different cities and like get high and
then ii and then do this one show i got
to do this miss number even though it
was like February March for everybody
lived perfect it was weird because they
didn't really know ganja and Kim that
well going in and like both room just
astounded me ganja is just a natural
performer and she has that it and then
Kim Chi is just so hilarious and shady
she is the shadiest elephant rhino beast
in the room really at all times Wow I
mean she knows where the best food is so
we didn't eat really well because I
would make sure everyone was medicated
and then we I mean yeah that you guys
are taking care of each other because it
was boo-boo in some towns and we were
like there's no heat in this theater and
we were dying yes
what's the because you try
so much and a lot of the the shows that
you do like you said are on the road
what's the biggest thing you've learned
or that you now like bring to prepare
yourself for that kind of intensity
extra tape oh yeah yeah extra duct tape
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a quick survival kit yeah I feel
like you just you just learned you have
to be really adaptable so I bring it all
I mean as far as like drag needs go you
know bring all the wig caps and the you
know bobby pins and just anything you
might need because yeah you never know
what's gonna happen or what's gonna
break or if you're late for the costume
change or just exactly what's gonna
happen always be prepared
what's bath mat from a hotel I learned
that from chat so your ties she does you
lay a towel out yeah that's very smart
first oh good call very very smart what
in your opinion is the biggest amateur
mistake people make when they start out
and drag I'm sure there's a time when
they think they're so pretty and they
don't need to cover their eyebrows okay
that was me I mean I guess when they try
to do the depth and they're not good mmm
very fair very fair you're not a dancer
just don't do it you know or like really
commit to trying but if you're somewhere
in between and you're sloppy I get real
shaky nervous laganja you also posted a
video recently with gia about being a
boss so what would you say and Willem
you two are the keys to being a boss
saving your money getting someone to do
your taxes and not mixing you know your
dick with your with your pleasure really
keeping those separate I think that's
great I think those are all really I
think surrounding yourself with smarter
people than you
yeah just like that's kind of what I've
done because I'm good at a lot of things
but I'm not great at anything so I just
have people that are really good at like
little other things that can help me in
my career and I just find like
being a boss is like also just allowing
other people to create around you and
trusting that you hire the right person
and made the right decision and like you
know it's collaborative for me being
able to communicate I think that's so
true though it's all about communication
if you're a boss because you have to
like pass on tasks to other people so
you have to be very clear in what you
want and how to like get that from the
right kind of people so that also goes
into like you said who you hire having
those the right people around you I love
being challenged by people - I'm all for
that and that's honestly one of the
reasons when I moved in next door to
Willam that I was like this will be
really good for me because Willam is
always creating her own book her own
makeup line her own her own her own and
as someone who is trying to be an
entrepreneur in that way and not just
following the footsteps of all the other
drag race girls it does it pushes you
and I love that for sure something it's
like a dream product or show or a
creative piece that you haven't worked
on yet that would be a dream to be
working on or producing hmm I definitely
would love to have my own dispensary run
by drag queens yeah you know a stage and
lounge area of course you know we just
got those licenses last year there's
about eight that were selected out of
thousands of applicants so it's going to
be a long process before I believe that
could really happen for me but I would
love to have that kind of a safe space
for people who in the queer community
could come and consume cannabis and see
drag shows and you know have it be
giving back to LGBTQ you know
organizations and that's definitely
something that I continue to work on of
course that's us Marcus owe me these
high drugs in their wake to no policy
here just out in the open lay it out I
think that's a great idea I really hope
that that comes to fruition after all of
this I think that's fantastic there we
go
I feel like you've kind of answered this
question but
do you watch or what do you consume to
relax so what are you it what do you
look at on the internet what are the
things that like when you have a second
to yourself that you just like escape to
um if anything like I am obsessed with
reality television so that's my big
go-to I'm come kind of a workaholic who
doesn't watch much TV so this quarantine
has made me catch up on stuff I've
really like superhero stuff watchman's
like the best thing i've ever seen the
boys was good I'm obsessed with insecure
what else yeah comedies I watched Dave
Chappelle a lot I just put that on
Family Guy American Dad Wow we could not
have more opposite tastes I'm like I
know what some of these shows are but I
don't watch any of these that's crazy
why is a handmade style mm-hmm oh I love
that one yeah oh and I watched I
definitely am a Netflix girl so right
now I'm addicted to Hollywood the ryan
murphy new series by hannah i was so
good so good
I loved ozarks I laugh of course the
tiger King movie that was awesome and
then of course my guilty guilty pleasure
right now is encore on the Disney Plus
app it's about people who are brought
back to do their high school musicals
again so a lot of them are 10 20 years
older haven't seen each other used to
date now they're being confronted and
then they also staged the whole play
again so it's a great great show I
bought the app literally just for that
show I've heard of that show I haven't
watched it is it's not cringy at all um
I love reality television like yourself
so I wouldn't say no you're gonna love
it I mean okay they definitely some of
them can't sing and maybe you cringe at
that but like you just feel for them
because it's so cool that they're you
know now nurses and coming back to
experience this as an adult I think it's
I don't know it moves me to tears for
sure I'm that girl oh that's very sweet
okay so will you've worked with Lady
Gaga it must have been a dream scenario
obviously best friends now look
who's a dream collaboration for you
Missy Elliott really yeah that's my
ultimate dream that's what I always tell
people I want to be like known as the
Missy Elliott of drag cuz I really do
want to make rap music and for the world
shaking my ass but yeah Elliott is she's
always been my hugest inspiration I have
a tattoo of her crown from the adidas
line that was known as respect me and
yes she's always been someone who I've
inspired by because she's able to take
pop music but also have a real message
behind it for instance like with super
duper freak when she wore the giant bat
suit making a you know commentary on how
black female bodies have been hyper
sexualized and so there's always
something real about her art and then
she's always able to make it mainstream
and poppy so that's kind of like what I
want to do to I want to I want to be
intellectual but I want other people to
still enjoy the art and I think that's
what she's done wow what a great answer
I would never have connected those dots
that's so cool I studied a course in it
in college and so that's also why how
kidding I didn't know that's it but
luckily I am interested in other
subjects and in school I I studied it
and I wrote my thesis on Missy Elliott
and why I think that she's like such a
cool pop star well you wrote a whole
thesis about Missy Elliott that's
amazing
that's incredible I'm sure you've all
been asked a billion times but what's
the first thing you'll do when this is
all over it was the thing that you can
do I mean for me I'm like on the fence
about I don't even know what it is I
don't even know what I'll feel
comfortable like getting into after this
but I'm curious if you're eager to do to
perform to travel to literally just like
walk down the street I don't know
I'm doing three things dick dick dick
similar to mine Hearst was just three
times mine was I was a dick but I liked
it three times that sounds here I really
want to go to Chili's I really wanna go
to Chili's that I yeah I'm with you get
some boneless wings see what happens
boneless wings and bone perfect
done and done BB okay we're gonna take
one last break when we get back we have
a bunch of really great Twitter
questions for you so we'll be right back
with more not your deep did you know
that there's a company that's mastered
the science of sparkle meat light box
lab grown diamonds they hacked a
billion-year process to grow stunning
lab-grown diamond stones in about two
weeks and they're some of the highest
quality stones that exist they're always
near colorless always vs clarity always
a very good cut and always $800 per
carat they come in three colors to white
blush pink and soft blue after they're
grown in the lab they're transformed
into gorgeous lab-grown diamond jewelry
it's Beauty meets brain go to light box
jewelry calm slash Grace and use code
grace for $25 off that's light box
jewelry dot-com slash grace use code
grace for $25 off okay before we get
into these Twitter questions I'm going
to ask you the two questions I ask every
single guest as on the podcast will and
I think you answered these before but
sometimes your answers will change the
first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti at
I love how serious of the pregnant
pauses free-thinking about it okay go
ahead some [ __ ] yeah I was gonna say
Trump but to be different I'll say
tige okay any any reason or just leave
it at that I just think he deserves it
he's not really a fan of the homosexuals
so I would just like to let him taste my
cold spaghetti okay and the other
question is every guest is to tell us
your worst pants shooting story or close
call but you can only tell us in three
words or three small phrases so mine for
example is college jogging front lawn
douche water on stage drip riffle bull
yeah oh it was beer though because it
was a butt chug chug Wow how do you beat
that okay - ramen noodle Walmart's white
capris paints a very specific picture
and I thank you for sharing with us and
I thank you okay let's get into these
Twitter questions first one is how did
you find your start and make up and
eventually your style for drag
experimenting just you know you you look
at what girls doing something like let
me do that cuz I am just like experiment
mm-hmm I was really lucky I had a couple
queens like kind of really walked me
through it in the beginning there was a
queen her name is Ali cat she's I don't
think she does drag anymore but she
really helped me out here in Los Angeles
and then eventually Vivienne Pinay
really walks me through a lot of things
too but I also AM like an avid Utes
YouTube watcher for makeup tutorials so
I definitely right now I'm obsessed with
mmm Mitchell I think he's amazing
ah next question is what's the weirdest
thing that you've done during quarantine
I feel like there could be so many
things there maybe nothing
my French you what defrosted my fridge
defrosted your fridge mm-hmm okay was it
frozen in the freezer like the big ice
cello yeah yeah yeah I got them out I
sucked a fight okay
on camera or is this private it was
private someone wants to someone's
asking I'd like to ask Willem how is it
to always have a front row seat when
laganja does these amazing shows in her
backyard oh my god so good sometimes I
don't have ones though and she throws
when she does have the one she uses one
of those like grippers to reach novelty
right it's later yeah you're still being
responsible good for you not just a song
that's right
okay Willem and laganja are casting a
slasher film but the gag is they can
only cast three rue girls each who are
they casting and who will be the last
one standing
I would you kill me in ganja oh and
who's the last one standing okay
I love a queen that casts herself so I'm
gonna say me and Willem and then I would
pick to throw a spicy labor I'm gonna
say peaches Christ I'll pick the other
person who was in our cast okay I think
she would truly be the last one standing
she's the most wise and I honestly think
we'd all eat him to survive so I feel
like you know it would be peaches he
thought it through I appreciate it
tips on getting sexy while in lockdown
any tips take your clothes off put
whipping cream in your bedside table and
use a whip like a PSA Willam any tips on
getting sexy and in quarantine I've been
trying to write once a day even try know
what once a day what okay if you had to
choose between sickening shoes or
sickening hair which do you choose
I know Williams answer I do hair I knew
it and I would do shoes yeah without
naming names can you share the craziest
story or experience you've had working
with another rude girl Alyssa Edwards I
mean miss mission efforts without saying
her name yeah I was it was a unique gig
I did a couple with her but I can't I
couldn't have thought they would end up
how they happened divas of drag is that
what you're thinking no but I heard
about that one
on that one now I love that was later
remember and had the box over my head
were you there for that for which she
was supposed to be at at or but there
were there a problem
uh-huh she couldn't be at that show so
they had me go down to San Diego and I
were a big fur coat and a box on my head
that said ELISA because it was Christmas
Jacqueline and meesh drove down to like
take pictures with the girls in the mean
green and they saw me and they wouldn't
take pictures it's always an outrageous
time with her let's just say that it's
always it a gaggle of giggles for sure
yeah I can only imagine someone to know
how do you come up with your concepts
for all of your looks just mix and match
for me personally I like to do pieces
like for instance like right now so then
like the next time I wear this I'd
probably wear the skirt with a different
top or you know so I like to mix and
match a lot of my looks and I guess I'm
most inspired by whatever I can afford
[Laughter]
okay last question before we wrap things
up thoughts on season 12
I love it yeah I I like that there's no
like villain really so like you're
seeing a lot of just like good happy
people doing drag competitive whatever
but like it doesn't it seems like
they're letting the talent shine through
without having to force some story here
and it's refreshing yeah I agree
I definitely think it's been one of
their better seasons I find there to be
a nice mix of girls that contrast one
another and I really find that it's just
been even better because we're stuck in
quarantine I don't know it's like for me
I always watch the shows when I'm at the
bar so I'm not truly watching them or
truly like I guess as invested as I am
right now because there's literally
nothing else to do but actually wash and
take in every second so I'm loving it
I'm totally a fan of so many of the
girls this season and I can't wait to
see what happens
I do wish there was a trans girl on this
season period we can't let it go without
saying because I can't the opportunity
that we get for to be interviewed I mean
the same kind of opportunities should be
given to all people in the drag field
and those girls deserve a chance so we
have to say on every podcast it's a new
rumor I agreed for you know what's next
what's coming up what's what's in the
works for you well I've been working on
my album hi Connick for the last two
years I was supposed to release in July
but obviously due to COBIT I haven't
been able to get back to Atlanta to
finish it out but I definitely want to
be releasing that within this year and
obviously everything that comes with
that music videos tours merch the whole
nine yards
amazing can you give any little like
teasers on what people can expect from
it
sure it's definitely all club bangers
I've released two singles so far look at
me and smoke break so if you're wanting
to truly get a good idea of what to
expect you can listen to those two songs
but as I said before I'm trying to be
the Missy Elliott of drag so it's hip
hop driven awesome beats catchy rhymes
that hopefully also mean a little
something to
just expect it to be very like cannabis
centric I mean it's hi Connor yeah
really great thanks I'm working on the
trademark limb what's next for you I
mean not like you don't have twelve
thousand things that you're working on
right now I this is kind of like forced
me to chill a little bit but I'm just
working on another book in YouTube's and
trying Shia's properties
yeah I'm trying to get like a Palm
Springs place like up and running just
in time for no Airbnb yeah and it's got
like a drag room in it for people like
get up and drag so I'm working okay not
ready to be opened by the summer it was
supposed to be Coachella but yeah yeah
that's about it really million on
YouTube that's my goal this year like
I'm at 9:18 and I want the big it can
happen I believe in that [ __ ] how big
is it the plaque yeah um you know it's
it's it's the size of you'll be able to
carry it around you can put it in your
back seat I was gonna put it on a chain
oh maybe not but no you actually in your
you might be able to I think you could
pull that off
before you go all of our guests when we
do this in person get a personalized
fortune cookie from us to you but we're
gonna try and do it digitally so I think
Melissa's gonna send you your
personalized fortune cookie if possible
and maybe you can read your fortunes out
loud for us
well mu of yours okay feel free to read
yours aloud okay mine says depending on
the wig and where you stand it may cause
someone to think you're a Karen act with
caution
oh very ominous and foreboding y'all
wrote these these are supposed to be
personal
they're only within reason well y'all
are hateful mine just says run I mean
you're running your own potential
cannabis parlor so good
oh great
okay now where can everyone find you on
the internet and everything that you're
up to if they don't already know I'm at
Willimon everything yeah and I'm at
laganja estranja
except on tick tock because some little
teenager took it so I'm the only laganja
estranja on tick tock wonderful and
thank you again for making time during
this weird time to come and podcast with
me this was so fun I wish you all luck
on everything that you're doing I'm so
excited for everything and thank you
guys for listening and watching we'll
see you next time on another episode of
not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep Christ back not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]